hoy en yereván se llevaron adelante los
actos conmemorativos del aniversario 106
del genocidio armenio perpetrado por las
autoridades del imperio otomano a raíz
del cual un millón y medio de armenios
fueron masacrados ayer por la noche se
realizó la tradicional marcha de las
antorchas hasta el memorial del
genocidio armenio y hoy a lo largo de
todo el día se recibieron las visitas
oficiales de las autoridades de armenia
a las cuales se sumaron delegaciones de
diferentes partes del mundo el día en
armenia concluye con la conmovedora
noticia del reconocimiento del genocidio
armenio por parte del presidente de los
eeuu joe biden quien calificó a las
masacres de 1915 como genocidio a lo
largo de estos años casi 30 países han
tomado medidas similares reconociendo el
genocidio armenio oficialmente pero esta
declaración del ejecutivo de los eeuu
fue realmente muy ansiado por parte
de todos los armenios del mundo
especialmente por la comunidad armenia
de este país quien ha llevado adelante
una labor incansable para lograr este
objetivo